So we've all got standard-issue tongues, taste
buds, brains. Why does food taste differently
to different people?
Anthony here for Dnews. I am NOT hot sauce
fan and my dad loves. He puts that on everything.
I have a friend who loves the taste the black
licorice, but black licorice makes me sick.
The three of us are from similar cultural
backgrounds, so why don't we like the same
stuff?
Now some people are super tasters and some
are subtasters.
Super tasters have an ability that you probably
already guessed. They can taste subtleties
that other people can't.
Subtasters are far less sensitive and there's
an easy way to tell which one you are.
But first, a little bit about your sense of
taste. Okay you've got your taste buds. They're
mostly on your tongue, but you've also got
some on your throat and on the roof of your
mouth.
Each one is contained in something called
a fungiform papillae.
Now using these miraculous receptors, you
are hard-wired to experience five different
kinds and tastes: sweet, sour, salty, bitter
and umami.
Now umami is basically savory. It's named
in Japanese because that's where it was discovered.
Now there's some current research that says
we're also specifically built to taste fat,
but we're not sure of that.
Now you can taste those flavors anywhere on
your tongue. A lot of people have been told
that you can only experience different flavors
on different sections, but that's actually
a misconception that comes from some very
outdated research.
So, everything you taste has some combination
of those five flavors in different intensities.
And that's where everything gets there unique
taste.
Now people with a high density of fungiform
papillae are much more sensitive to those
different tastes. Those are the super tasters.
They tend to favor things that are more mild.
Now super tasters also have subtle brain differences
in an area called the gustatory cortex, conveniently
located next to the bits that control chewing
and swallowing.
That's some good organization, brain.
Super tasters also tend to have heightened
senses of smell because smell is intensely
connected to taste.
But what's the benefit? Why is it good to
be a super taser and why are we wired to taste
those five specific flavors?
Well, sweet foods are high in calories so
when we were hunter-gatherers, finding high-calorie
food was important for survival.
Bitter tastes signal poisonous plants like
that black licorice flavor.
Salty foods have important minerals and vitamins.
So a super taster can find healthier foods
and avoid dangerous ones more easily.
Now about 25 percent of the population are
super tasters and there's an easy test to
figure out whether you are one of them.
First, drill a small hole into your skull
above the gustatory cortex.
What?
Okay I'm not allowed to do that one.
Here's a test from PopSci instead. Grab some
blue food coloring, and put it all over your
tongue.
Blue dye cannot stick to your taste papillae,
so if your tongue doesn't look like a smurf,
you're most likely super tester.
If it looks like mine, you're a sub taster.
But WHATEVER!
I don't want to have a cool sensitive palate
anyway.
Test yourself and let me know your results.
Throw your favorite and least favorite flavors
in down below so we can see just how accurate
all this is and subscribe for more Dnews.